hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
advanced enzymes to facilitate sars kobe
2 research
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions
that you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speaker lee
lavelle
senior product manager reverse
transcription at thermo fisher
scientific
lee you may now begin your presentation
thanks jennifer for the intro hello
everyone
i appreciate you attending this webinar
and i it's my pleasure to share with you
the information about
how next-generation engineer enzymes
were used in the stars kobe 2 research
let's go ahead and start
due to covet pandemic a broad range of
interests have been triggered in
understanding the mechanism the buyers
and identifying solutions to address
this global crisis
a lot of effort goes into the viral
research
virus detection prevention and the
treatment
for the viral research there are studies
focusing
on genome transcriptome characterization
pathogenesis mechanism virus
evolution and other aspects
the detection of south korea ii has
become
the focused research programs there are
also
a number of initiatives aiming for
vaccine and antivirus therapeutic
development
now we come to our very first poll
question
i was thankful that you will take a
little bit time fill out this
whole question
okay let's continue currently
start kobe 2 virus research is focused
on three directions
according to the technologies used
their target detection high throughput
sequencing
and cloning for targeted detection
rtqpcr
is the gold standard has been adopted by
majority
labs for virus detection
the researchers also explore rtland
and crispr based methods for point care
use
i'm going to share a little bit more
information about target detection in
the next few slides
for high throughput sequencing ngs is
the dominant method
with flexible strategies for example
the researchers can choose to use whole
genome or targeted sequencing
or whole transcriptome analysis other
than that
single molecule long-range sequencing
such as nanopore sequencing also gained
popularity
in virus research i will share more
in the later slides cloning has been
used in many applications
that involve rtp cr senior sequencing
a number of the number of cloning
techniques
the current colva 19
pandemics present a a serious
public health crisis and a better
understanding of the scope and spread of
virus will be
aided by more widespread testing
here's three different types of nuclear
acid testing
has been explored so i will use this
slide to give you an overview the
standard rtqpcr method
is is being wildly adopted
by a lot of labs patient and nasal swab
or saliva samples are collected and the
viral
particles are inactivated and lysed
pda essences and subsequent pcr
amplification
are performed with either a crude sample
or purified rna targeting specific
regions
of the virus genome for detection
a popular alternative to rt qpcr
is isothermal amplification which does
not
require thermal cycling
the major techniques are loop mediated
isothermal amplification lamp
i'm sure you have heard about this term
before
and the recombinant polymerase
amplification rpa
length uses a strand depleasing
displacing dna polymerase with
specifically designed
nested primers with
complementary regions that form hairpins
to permit priming of subsequent rounds
of amplification
the same process repeat and repeat it
around the priming and strand extension
generate a mixture of stem loop
and cauliflower structured products
the release of hydrogen ions can be
detected using
colometric ph indicator dyes
the rpa uses a recombinase
to catalyze strand invasion
of primer into double-stranded dna
single-stranded binding proteins are
included
to stabilize the open duplex structure
and strand displacing dna polymerase
extends to primer
some researchers can use both
rpa and the lens in a two-stage
amplification protocol
to improve specificity and sensitivity
the third category for is crispr-based
detection method a unique group of cast
nucleus such as cast 12
and cast 13 were discovered to possess
dna or rna cleavage activities
this feature has been exploited for
nucleic acid detection
the test non-specific nucleus
remains inactive until it finds its
program
rna or dna target the reporter molecules
are cleaved
releasing a fluorescent dye from a
quencher
the right hand graph shows the limit
of detection across different methods
you can see rtqpcr is still the most
sensitive method
that's why the majority testing still
come from rtq pcr
other methods can
use to detect as low as 10 molecules
okay let's take a look at the second
pole question
this slide shows you sars code 2
analysis workflow
it includes rna extraction
from a number from a variety of sample
sources
as listed here nasal swab and
saliva samples and the more common
sarcoid ii samples and researchers can
pick
environmental samples blood samples and
other type samples
to extract rna
the purified rna will be reverse
transcribed amplified
that analyze in different ways based on
the protocol workflows
some examples are electrophoresis
through
real-time fluorescence for sequencing
starts code 2
what i want to point out is in this
slide is sample
preparation and enzyme choice are
interconnected
usually a good high quality rna sample
may only require regular enzyme like mlv
reverse transcriptase or dna polymerase
however
if degraded rna samples or low input
rna is used a better enzyme is required
in this case
because the battery enzymes help deal
rna
or dna targets of sub sub optimal
purity and abundance
stars code 2 has enlarged has emerged
in 2019 and has rapidly spread worldwide
it is a positive sense single-stranded
rna virus
with five cap and three poly a tail
it's the longest rna virus about 30
kilobases
the clinical viral samples are easily
degraded during transportation
and rna extraction other challenges
include long testing time and
multiplexing challenges
a number of features should take
consideration
when you select enzyme reagent to study
sarcoma 2
virus the preferable feature of the
enzyme
include high processivity
faster speed better specificity
accuracy and ability to multiplex should
be considered
for circle 2 research here i just want
to point out
processivity is defined as
the number of nucleotides incorporated
during a binding event for example
the wild-type mlv reverse transcriptase
can
incorporate 50 nucleotides
in one binding event with engineered
next generation enzymes such as super
screen 4
the incorporation number much higher it
could accomplish 1500
nucleotides incorporation in one binding
event
so the processivity is much higher
and this can be translated into the high
speed
so some next generation enzyme examples
listed here
for the reverse transcriptions
superscripts four regions
they're all pretty good candidate for
study
to start called to research and
for the in dna polymerase
platinum superfight two dna polymerase
currently has the highest
fidelity is a three hundred fold more
fidelity than any
uh current high cedar dna polymerase on
the market
high fidelity is very important
essential
feature to be used for cloning
applications
and sequencing applications
okay now we can zoom in to talk
a little bit more about viral target
amplifications
i'm going to share two methods rtqpcr
and rtlan
and the featured regions are listed here
in superscript three one staff and super
square four also bst dna polymerase
i'm going to share a number of
publications
who recommend a number of rtqp cell
protocols for start cover 2 detection
this protocol using super 3 3 and
phantom tag
is one of them following the
recommendation a german group tested
this protocol
and purified rna samples amplified
using one step rt qpcr with gene
specific primers targeting rdrp
and e-genes their specific signals were
significantly
reduced in the superscript 3 one-step
setup
compared to quantity tag another rte
enzyme which used as
a reference this protocol is
demonstrated to be a fast
and sensitive protocol for virus
detection
the protocol can be done
can be downloaded on who website
i listed a link on the bottom of this
slide for your reference
in an effort to block
the wide of the widespread transmission
of shock coverage to wires
researchers from georgia state
university tested the efficacy
of drug compound mk4482
eidd 2801 against
stars pro 2 infection
in ferris models this compound has shown
potent anti-inflammatory
virus activity in the clinical trials
an administration of the drug compound
exhibited
reduction of virus load in upper
respiratory tract
and successfully block community
transmission
rtq-pcr was used to detect the virus
load
with rna purified from either harvest
organs
or pvmc samples
in addition the systematic interferon
and cytokine expression profiling is
performed with the real-time cyberbrain
and essay
now i would like to spend a little bit
time to compare the differences
between the gold standard detection
method rtqpcr
and rtlan rtqpcr method
requires trained personnel and a fully
equipped lab facility
rtlam is a more simplified method easy
to use
no special equipment needed it takes
shorter time to generate
results compared to rt qpcr
however rtlam has lower sensitivity
and specificity than rt qpcr
recently we published an application
note detailing
and optimized rtland protocol
this slide shows the simplified rtlam
protocol workflow designed
by us for rapid detection of start code
2. this
protocol does not require a new region
all the regions used in this protocol
our existing region can be ordered on
our website
it also provides templates to test the
protocol for additional targets with
other primer sets
the protocol the protocol starts with
magmax purified rna samples
all the components are combined together
to prepare reaction mix
direction mix include bsm dna polymerase
superscript 4 reverse transcriptase rna
template
and specifically designed six primers
after mixing all the components together
and the protocol goes through the
incubation
and inactivation steps
finally several endpoint methods to
visualize
the results are demonstrated such as
direct color visualization show
on the picture a and aggregate gel shown
picture b
so you can see the stars covered two
positive samples
and shows that different target band
from the line one to line five
and the korean there's a ukraine a
korean group and they actually
looking at develop their own version of
lamp rtlam the design evaluation rtlam
axis for detection start code 2 is and
limited of detection of 100 copies
per reaction
so they actually an extracted rna
from a culture medium of the
covalent to infected cells
and superscript 4 reverse transcriptions
with bsc dna
polymerase and used for cdn synthesis
and amplification and the visual
calories color magics visualization
can be performed as shown in the graph
on the right hand side
you can see is this message sensitive
enough can only detect
color change with source code too
you know are no template control and
some similar
and virus sequences and you don't see
the color change
so the visualization this the detection
can be also performed with
re read rt
qpcr method
now let's take a look at the deep
sequencing for virus detection research
we are switchgear to take a look at
ngs method and nanopore sequencing and
other sequencing method
the super 34 reverse transcript is
typically used
for this type of application i'm going
we're going to look at a number of
applications
if sequencing plays a critical role in
source code b2 research
it offers single base sensitivity to
investigate virus
variants there's no prior sequence
knowledge required
compared to pcr-based methods it's also
a common method to study
host pathogen interactions with complete
and high coverage
researchers can choose whole genome
sequencing or target sequencing
ngs or single molecule sequencing
the scales of the studies can be large
or small
australia researchers analyzed
over two transmission pathways in
australia
by south carolina genome sequencing this
publication happened
a few m a few months after the global
pandemic happens
so they want to identify which
portion actually locally acquired which
portion of cases
actually imported from overseas the
collective clinical samples
collected on the clinical samples with
positive rpp cell results
these samples were reversed transcribed
using superscript 4 willow master mix
the viral cdnas were amplified by
multiplex pcr
with plentium superfly pcr master mix
amplicons were then pulled purified
and quantified followed by library prep
using extra xt library preparation kit
only a quarter of the sequenced cases
appear to be locally acquired
this high resolution genomic data are
crucial to take
cases with locally acquired kovi 19 and
overseas
importation
how do we decide if the enrichment is
needed for sequencing
so this really depends on research goal
if the purpose to
is just focus on the viral genome
the viral genome needs to be enraged by
either amplification based on
hybridization
or amplification method the overall
sequencing cost will be reduced
the majority reads would map to the
south cov2 genome
however if the research goal is to
analyze host pathogen interactions
no enrichment will be required you will
gain a whole picture with
reads covering a variety of different
different genomes with human genome over
70 percent
and less than three percent reads mapped
to south kore-2
genome
we developed an optimized workflow for
sequencing the source kobe 2 genome
you may download it from our website
of the downloads the app notes from our
website
this application this application node
details the protocol starting from rna
purification total rna was extracted
from bal clinical specimen the applied
biosystem magmax
viral nuclear acid isolation kit was
used
for purification difference to group
four
valo master mix and thermal scientific
second strand cd intensive kit was used
for cdna services
the sequencing ready library was
prepared with clibbery
and the enzymatic sharing dna library
preparation kit
with unique dual indexes the library
were pulled and raised using a synthetic
probe panel by pcr amplification
the step is option this step is optional
the final concentration of libraries
were quantified
with cleavery library quantification kit
then sequence on the
illumina system here list the time
takes for each step so the entire
workflow
may take one to two days
um so this is a nice study published on
sale and the last year the crane
researchers they
established a high resolution
sharp kobe 2 transcriptome map
and they actually used to
match their sequence they used two
sequencing method
to do this to do the study and one
is um one is the
ngs sequencing by things is
like illumina or mgi system
and they use the they use the nano pro
base to direct the rna sequencing
for the rest of uh for the rest of the
studies
so they started total rna actually
purified from the virus
infected virus infected cells
and the viral cdna things is using
superscript 4
rt enzyme followed
by the pcr amplification and gel
purification and then
they will perform the
individual transcriptome
and they will able to follow the
the manufacturing protocol to perform
direct rna sequencing library
and using superscript 4 rt enzyme
this is a two arm approach using two
different
sequencing system to verify the data
so what they found is there are numerous
discontinuous transcriptome events
at least the 41 potential rna
modification sites were identified
stars poverty 2 also produces rna
encoding unknown
open reading frames first
so this is a really nice study to map
out
the entire transcription map
so this study showing
the recently we see that
there's a new varying strain
and called b117 variant
and the first identify the uk kingdom
and everyone knows about this stream is
really
have a high profile on the medium
everybody reported about it
and they had gained a strong for
foothold around the world
and in december in california first
and the researchers identified this
and this the virus and they collected
a number of clinical samples
and those samples already verified with
pcr as positive samples and
from there they will end using both
rna sequencing and rt qpcr
to method to confirm the b117 variant
and they are they show the bb1 b117
rapidly become the dominant star
kobe 2 variant in the us us will
share the similar trajectory as
the other country where the b
the new variant b117 is spread
so this study shows uh another way to
and analyze the the stars
cov2 with ngs so currently
when the patients show the symptom they
get
detected to show the positive negative
so the early detection using rtqpcr
is the only way to predict viral load
even
though there are some patients with no
symptoms
this is the imperfect readout in this
case
so group researchers from national
university of
singapore they determined to
identify a better predictor of the viral
load
they developed a viral long fragment
for this is based on the sequencing
and sequencing of the viral lung
fragment
first of all dna are rna purified from
nasal saliva samples
and they the reverse transcription
performed
using applied biosystem high capacity
and reverse transcriptase
and amplified by the multiplexing
pcr using plantium superfly 2 dna
polymerase
the library um is prepared
following the the regular protocol
and and then the illumina system was
used and paradigm 2 by 150 base pair
sequencing was
performed and that they proved that ngs
actually
indeed a very sensitive method to detect
long rna fragments
the bond is long fragment and the score
is positively
associate the wider load and the
inversely
associated with the
time from the disease onsite in another
word
the longer the disease has been
diagnosed the
score the viral lung fragment score will
be lower
so they designed the primers for 327
amplicons
and with 155 stars covered two positive
samples
okay so after sharing two technology in
lessons
so we're scared to take a look at
cloning so cloning typically
involved rt pcr a different cloning
technique and the center sequencing
so the popular product used for the
cloning applications
include superscript for one step and
first strand synthesis
systems plentium superfly two dna
polymer is another popular
option because of its high fidelity
okay here's our post question
i appreciate you answer that question
let's wait here for a little bit
now we move to another publication
a german um yes a group
a group from
the university of texas they actually
developed this method
called isa and this will reverse the
established reverse genetic
of coronal virus by infectious sub
genomic amplifications method
so the this method has been developed in
recent years
on focus on the short single strand
rna genome and this is the first
publications they established and
the first publications established on
the
long rna strand
so the researchers and they
use this technology and in
with a purpose no in need for
constructing a full genomic
cdna mutations and the fluorescent
reporter genes
were incorporated in this case so first
of all
they designed and eight overlapping
denoble synthetic
viral fragments uh you they use
this fragments as a template to
synthesize cdna
using superscript four one step rdpcr
system
then the cdnas were amplified
with super phi 2 dna polymerase
and this amplified for fragments were
transfected into cells the fluency
recombinant
viral genome was produced within the
cells
through the invaluable dna combination
the full length viral genome were then
verified by one step
rtp crsa
so constructed genome it turned out
is completely identical to that of
targeted virus
the rescued virus replicates the
phenotypic and genotypic characteristic
of original isolate
university of university researchers
developed a re a
another reverse genetic system
to study sarcoidovirus the viral rna
purified from
viral e6 cells were used as a template
for rtpcr to produce cdna fragments
their seven cdn fragments were
constructed
to overlap the entire the viral genome
so the four of them are chemically
synthesized
three of them went through the
traditional cloning process because
those three fragments not stable
by the chemical synthesis
so the cdna was re was
a synthesized using super screen 4 first
strand city and synthesis kit
and then amplified using superfine 2
polymerase
all cds fragments are individually
cloned
the rna turns right from the full-length
cdas
were highly infectious exhibited similar
plague morphology viral rna profile
and replication kinetics
and in addition this system generates
stable reporter genes
and it can be used to evaluate the
antivirus activities potential
therapeutics so it turned out to be a
really valuable system for the drug
screening process
a german group analyzed antibody
response of
12 kovat 19 patients from
eight to six and nine days after
diagnosis
the neutralizing antibodies showed a
broad spectrum of variable genes
and a low-level somatic mutation
this demonstrates stars code
to neutralizing antibodies
are readily generated from a diverse
pool of precursors
and giving us the hope for rapid
induction of a protective immune
response upon vaccination
in this study cervical two active domain
specific
b cells were isolated from pbmcs
single cell amplification antibody
having light trains
was performed using super screen 4.
reverse for reverse transcription plenty
of tech hot start polymerase for
amplification
the pcr products were then analyzed by
gel electrophoresis followed by single
sequencing
so lastly and
i would like to share with you about the
benefits like already enzyme formulation
it requires in a process
called lyophilization this is a water
removal process
used to preserve perishable materials to
extend the shelf life or make the
material more convenient
for transport drug and diagnostic
acid developers their interest in this
process
however the conventional formulation
enzyme contain up to 50 percent
glycerol which stabilize
sterilizes enzymes but interferes with
leo fertilization process a good light
already enzyme
should be formulated with glycerol
content level
well below 0.5
in the meantime maintain equivalent
performance
of reproducibility sensitivity and
specificity
to the com compared to the conventional
formulation
okay let's pause here for our last four
questions
so when considering
a light ready enzyme for nuclear acid
amplification
there are three different categories you
can consider one is performance
here at least the different performance
important
is inhibitory tolerance thermal
stability processivities but specificity
low residual dna contamination and
in terms of consistency you would like
to take the
bioready enzyme and have very similar
good qc test from batch to batch and
minimize
any variation introduced from the
different batches
and the quality will be good to pick
from
the facility iso certified facility
high quality facility to manufacturing
live ready enzymes
okay this concludes my presentation
today
i appreciate any questions you may bring
up
thank you
okay here is our last question last poll
question
thank you for your attention
thank you lee for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
what's the multiplex capacity of the
platinum superfi dna polymerase
and how does universal annealing
temperature work
that's a very good question actually
there's no limitation
with the enzyme itself in terms of how
many multiplex reactions can be
incorporated
is can be used for many many targets
in one reaction the limitation factor
actually from the different
components it really is combination of
how much
primers in one reaction and what's the
other component that's the limiting
factors
the more on the more interaction
inc put together in one reaction the
more
enzyme the more primers and the more
um buffer that everything has to be
optimized
but the enzyme itself can accommodate as
many
reactions as possible and in terms of
universal
temperature that's a really really good
feature
we have with superfine to
polymerase as well as plantium
pack heart start enzyme so we have this
innovation
to optimize the buffer condition
so in the past it's very inconvenient
when designing the different primer sets
and have to optimize the melting
temperature
to is
to a similar level so making the new
lint temperature is more or less the
same
but with the current formulation and you
can design
the whatever primers you need it without
worrying about
similar the annealing temperature you
can just throw all your primer set
together
and then the buffer condition will take
care of that they will be able to
use the universal condition to carry out
the reaction hopefully i answer your
question
thank you lee our next question here is
for detection of the covavirus what's
your thought on using purified rna
versus adding samples directly to the rt
reaction
that's another good question initially
when the research developed the
detection method workflow always starts
with purified rnas
there are some limiting factors with the
global pandemics the more and more
need for widespread nuclear acid testing
there's not enough the rna purification
kit that's
become bottlenecked i see that there is
a
significant slow down the diagnosis
process because uh
the limitation from the rna library
preparation
kit and so there is more and more
researchers think about alternative
solution which is
how about we skip rna purification just
like
the samples and directly carried out to
the
rtq pcr or rt lamp this is a good
concept which is being studied a lot
the um the con for this method
actually is the compatibility between
the transportation medium as you know
those clinical samples saliva or
the nasal swab need to put in the
transportation medium
transfer to the lab and then and process
for the next step
if the transporter medium not compatible
with
super straight um superscript or reverse
transcriptase in general
and that's a great problem and
there's uh some considerations like
sensitivities
and different background noise also need
to consider
but in general in direct approach using
crude samples will be faster
more straightforward and can bypass that
and bottleneck from the rna isolation
kit supply issues
okay great thank you so much lee and our
next question here
is can you please elaborate more on
processive processivity
yeah processivity is as i mentioned in
the presentation
is the defined as
the number of nucleotides cooperated in
a single binding
event so the wild type typically have 30
to
50 nucleotides incorporated in one
binding event
you can imagine when they cooperate
low number of nucleotides it takes
longer time
to finish the cdna synthesis and using
reverse transcriptase as example
and for the engineered enzyme and
superscript 4
is much faster it can incorporate
as many nucleotides as possible so far
we see that 1
500 nucleotides and there's a 500
fold the difference basically between
the wild type
and the engineered enzyme so the
advantage of this
as i mentioned earlier is fat right it's
just
moving really fast it takes only 10
minutes to reverse transcription
compared to
the wild-type rt enzyme and also it can
translate
to how we can overcome the rt inhibitors
in the reaction mix
typically with a slow lower processivity
enzyme
when there is some inheritance or
introduced
the inhibitors in the reaction the rt
enzyme will typica the traditional
organza will slow down
and will not be able to finish the
synthesis of full-length cdna
but with high processivity enzyme it
will be overcome
the anti-inhibitors or sub-optimal rna
qualities
they overcome that issue still get
pretty decent cdna thinks this results
um yeah that's a really big benefit for
the
next generation enzyme
right thank you lee and we have time for
one more question
how do i decide which workflows i should
use one step
rt pcr or two-step rtpcr
the one step rtpcr is a fact
convenient can be avoided
can be used to minimize the potential
contamination
introduced by two stack because there's
more pipetting steps involved
and that's the advantage using one step
rtpcr
in this case the gene-specific primer
required
and so the knowledge about the genome
or about the sequences is needed
and so this one-step rtpc are very
extremely popular and necessary
for the detection gene detection world
for diagnosing the quick
and um simple to resolve world
so typically one step rtpcr is used to
detect
or to detect a virus but for the
research world
in one step rtpcr there is lack of
flexibility
and researchers cannot optimize the
conditions
everything already added in one tube and
there's a limited
power for them to optimize their assets
so two steps our tpcr system will be
really um will be typically used
was typically used by the researchers in
the lab and
like sequencing projects or any new
method to develop
to typically use two to matter two
methods you could
use random primers and oligodt to
basically synthesize the cdna
across the board and then pick the
gene-specific primers to amplify
for the second step
yeah hopefully i have answered your
question
you lee do you have any final comments
for our audience today
i want to thank you everyone to spend
time
with me and to going over this older
publications what enzyme can be used
to accomplish what purpose is i'm sure
this short presentation cannot cover
every single aspect
of covet research with this center stage
our daily life
which is profoundly impact all of us
and i i want to first of all thank all
the researchers
and and to end up in
this effort to overcome this pandemic
provide a solution for us for all of us
and also we are so proud to provide
solutions
raising solutions to help the
researchers
we definitely have large selection of
different
enzymes we are well known for the high
quality
dna polymerase and
the our reverse transcriptase so
please check out our website to see
what enzyme will meet your needs
and and we'll be happy to provide
any solutions if you have any questions
we'll be happy to answer
and please contact our sales team for
any questions you have
thank you again lee for your time today
and for your important research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye